in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions PJ and
Dana are with us hey how are y'all hey
thank to be here welcome welcome were
you from Chilhowie Virginia very cool
very cool I love it now what is
Chilhowie near Bristol Oh near the line
there Bristol Motor Speedway yeah
beautiful area beautiful area the
country and beautiful mountains there we
were up to the Bristol while back it's
really a neat area well cool welcome to
Nashville and you're here to do a
debt-free scream yes how much have you
paid off eighty-three thousand six
hundred nine dollars and seventy one
cents I love it
and how long did that take you six years
four months and one day very good and
your range of income through that six
years four months in one day we started
out at ninety thousand total income and
the job position changed we went to
eighty thousand and we're currently
making around 110 thousand right now
excellent what do you guys do I am a
supervisor of a large manufacturing
plant or refrigerated trailers okay and
been no company twenty seven and a half
years alright very cool very cool what
about your Dana I work for CBS called
commercial business systems they build
computer systems with you credit unions
all right very good well very good you
guys have worked your tail off so is
this house and everything no no that
consumer damn got it and what kind of
debt was the eighty four thousand credit
cards and vehicles okay all right Creek
sixty four thousand that was just credit
card alone I got you okay
twenty thousand on the vehicles yes yes
all right and so there's got to be a
story here with us being six years to
get through this yes there must have
been a journey tell me about it well
it's come with a lot of sacrifice we
actually a blended family we put three
kids my three kids and her two kids
together and to start out with we were
we just lived on the edge we just my
motto is we'll pay it back later so we
just we just did everything you know we
bought a new house remodeled added rooms
to it pretty much just wanted to get the
kids stuff that we didn't have
that's what got you in trouble oh wow
blame many kids but we're just so me we
we just meant like sure well you had it
yeah
and but six years ago you start getting
out of that yeah at six years agos when
the whole thing started that's the only
hit the wall yeah I went to the grocery
store one day and I tried to use two
credit cards and they were maxed out to
buy groceries with and so when I finally
got one to work and I got home I
actually got all my credit card bills
out on the table and looked at him I had
really never looked at even what the
balances were on them ever and so I just
it's like it just hit me in the face you
know I'm wearing all this debt and I
couldn't believe it and I didn't know
what to do he gets home from work yeah
and you're like oh my god I know I mean
it was just
I know people wouldn't believe that but
I mean I just paid the minimum payments
and OH
paid attention you know to what how much
we owed on him so our first thought was
we we gotta file bankruptcy because we
didn't know what else to do
and we actually made an appointment to
do that but then I didn't want to do
that because I knew it wasn't the right
thing to do but it was like we didn't
see any other way out so one night one
of my friends called me from the grocery
store actually to get a recipe and she
was we were talking about you know being
in debt and everything and she told me
she had gotten your book your Total
Money Makeover book and she offered to
let me borrow it and I did and I read it
in three nights and he read it and we'd
said we cancelled the bankruptcy
appointment and we started working on
our debt Wow
the reason it took so long was because
well we had a wedding my daughter got
married and so we had to kind of stop
during that time and then we also went
one whole winter without heat so that we
could save money for two heat pumps whoa
oh my gosh we heated part of her house
with electric heaters and the other Pete
pump was running on emergency heat only
till we saved the money to buy new heat
pumps yeah oh my gosh so you've had some
big expenses along the way in addition
to the 84 thousand right and it's came
with some sacrifice we we did everything
like you said you know you got to sell
things work
if you took our net income versus our
minimum payments it was mathematically
impossible to pay our bills we couldn't
do it so y'all had guns I've had since I
was just a young child so I started
selling off guns tools I didn't need I
picked up extra work on the weekends I
worked pretty much every weekend for the
last four or five years just learning
artwork and handyman work and stuff and
making money to pay that off so how's it
feel to be free it feels great
that's a lot different found by
absolutely yes definitely
we sold our wedding bands during that
time too oh my gosh
yeah and our children went and and got
us new wedding bands that's cool yes so
they've been watching all this yes what
kind of an impact has it had on them
well er I think a good one
they said to begin here today really
inspires them to do better yeah three
oldest kids got to live during the
plastic age the two younger ones got to
live during the Dave Ramsey era electric
heaters and heat pumps and don't work
yeah okay that's the Dave Ramsey
wilderness all right I'm with you though
you live like no one else later you get
to live and give like no one else all
right
you guys are making 110,000 you don't
have any payments life is dadgum good
man that's at least a B and we're still
driving a nineteen year old car which I
call my ramsey mobile and the 16 year
old pickup truck Wow well now you're in
a position you can save up and move up
in car very good with flannel man well
PJ and Dana from Chilhowie Virginia
Bristol area eighty-four thousand
dollars paid off in six years four
months and one day making 90 to 80 to
110 during that time count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream three two one
well done you guys that's how it's done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head
and make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind